distanciation et physique oblige les
madelinots ont dû briser une tradition
vieille de 145 à se rendre très tôt sur
le quai pour celui les pêcheurs de
homards qui prennent le large 25 en 2020
santé et sécurité
mais grâce aux nouvelles technologies
ils ont pu assister cette grand messe
dans le confort de leur maison sur
facebook avec la collaboration de la
radio et de la télévision locale
l'imaginent à part avec mary j
les ja avec les bateaux par les
fournisseurs des images de sable des
votes vous avez du mal à l'imaginer les
tâches au mât d'une hauteur et une main
a lancé leur saison même si la cave et
10 9 a causé l'effondrement des
principaux marchés pour le droit des
crustacés 80% du homard vivant est
normalement vendus aux etats unis
la fois l'an dernier les pêcheurs
madelinots a été connu une saison record
avec 11 millions de livres d'omar mais
cette année la pacha commence sous le
signe de l'incertitude incertitudes
quant au prix et la durée de la saison
qui pourrait être écourtée si le marché
canadien de vis est juré la perte
pour le moment ses copains copains au
passé neuf semaines les 149 chardoman
gaspésie prenait tout si la mare samedi
et comme aux us si tout se passe comme
prévu les premiers arrivages sont
attendus dans les poissonneries de la
région demain pour le traditionnel
souper de la fête des mères
ici martin seule boîte radio canada
d'aspect